everything is happening in the united
states it's to keep us divided because
once the people wake up to who the real
enemy is which is the establishment
meaning joe biden donald trump the
republicans and the democrats
and as soon as they wake up to that
that's when the establishment's in
trouble so they have to keep us fighting
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kissing
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people delighted to say our brilliant
guest today is a comedian youtuber and
political commentator jimmy dore welcome
to trigonometry uh my pleasure thanks
for having me
it's a great pleasure to have you on
listen one of the things we've been
talking about a lot on the show is how
the polarization we saw politically in
the last few years has now made its way
into the covet conversation i know that
you and i and francis have all found
that uh in our case we recently had
covid uh and some people thought that
even talking about having coveted is
like selling out and uh we're sponsored
by pfizer now which is of course you
know
nonsense it's moderna
but
right
but with with you it was even weirder
because you got the jab you got double
jabbed and people were like well you
trust the government now and you were
like no i trust my doctor and then you
had some side effects from the vaccine
which were quite serious i understand uh
and when you talked about it people like
your anti-vaxx for talking about so so
what do you make of this whole place
that we find ourselves in
yeah it's remarkable how they can turn
everything into the
uh culture wars in the united states and
right now there's a big interest in the
united states
uh in keeping america fighting each
other
and uh there was a the problem wasn't
trump the problem was that the trump
supporters
flex their muscle
just like the uh people did in britain
when they passed brexit
and uh so they can't let the great
unwashed have a voice in politics
and that's so that's why these
culture wars in the united states have
been ramped up like crazy and everything
is a culture war and they're afraid of
people like joe rogan
um
and me who actually speaks to a broad
audience so
they've tried to make uh the fact that i
appeal uh uh you know i'm i'm a populist
and uh the fact that i try to work with
people
uh who wouldn't wouldn't be considered
lefty because we agree on issues like
ending wars
uh getting health care to people police
brutality stuff like that
uh you know student debt
marijuana uh all kinds of stuff that
we agree on across the aisle as they
used to say and that used to be a good
thing but now
that actually scares the [ __ ] out of the
establishment so anybody in the united
states
who uh tries to uh
uh actually
force change against the establishment
by working
together on ideas instead of politics
that scares them so
uh
when i had a thing to get them to vote
on was called forced to vote here in the
united
states and i was going to get them to
try to get them to flex their muscle to
force a vote in the congress
to bring medicare for all to everybody
in the united states you know we don't
have that because our
our government is run by corporations we
live in an oligarchy and that's not
hyperbole those are facts those have
been proven by a princeton study we live
in an oligarchy we don't have a
democracy our democracy was stolen from
us a long time ago and now they want to
pretend that what happened on january
6th
uh was a threat to our democracy we
don't have a democracy that was a threat
to our oligarchy but it wasn't really a
threat at all
but uh so everything is happening in the
united states it's to keep us divided
because once the people wake up to who
the real enemy is which is the
establishment meaning joe biden donald
trump the republicans and the democrats
uh and as soon as they wake up to that
that's when the establishment's in
trouble so they have to keep us fighting
and everything now is a culture war and
including the vaccines right
and everybody on the left uh decided to
be uncritical of the vaccines the
vaccine mandate uh
advisor of dr fauci
of anything that has to do with covet
policy if you have a critique of it
you're immediately slammed as an
anti-vaxxer look what happened to eric
clapton eric clapton got the vaccine got
injured by the vaccine and immediately
he's the worst person in the world
because he told people about his
reaction to the vaccine
that's not how science is supposed to
work it happened to me too so when i got
injured by the vaccine
i was still sick about five weeks after
my second jab
and so i tweeted it out i said hey i'm
still having all these symptoms
and people started calling me anti-vaxx
and a liar
and uh you you know that's not how
science works we know that there are
adverse reactions
uh to vaccines that's why there's a
thing called veyers
and so you're supposed to go report them
everybody knows and
what helps make science better is people
telling you their reactions to medicines
and vaccines and so you can make them
better but that's not what this is about
this is about you shutting up and going
along with the corporate narrative and
if you don't you're gonna get in trouble
you're gonna get it's a cult what has
happened in the united states is the
democratic party became a cult under
donald trump and they pushed an
evidence-free conspiracy theory called
russiagate for four straight years they
didn't accept the results of the 2016
election they said donald trump was a
traitor to our country he was working
for russia and uh the election was
rigged and there was a coup that
happened in our country and russia
committed it along with donald trump
so as soon as donald trump loses his
election he starts saying the same thing
and that's illegal
you can't do that the democrats and the
establishment did it for four straight
years but as soon as donald trump and
the republicans do the exact same thing
uh they're that's illegal you can't do
that you can't you can't mention it on
youtube you can't met you're considered
a conspiracy nut and you'll have your
channel taken down in fact primo nutmeg
he did have a video taken down
and or primo radical he calls himself
now uh because
he just took a question
uh about january 6th and and and about
uh voter fraud
and anyway so that's how so when they
have to uh censor like that
that tells me they're afraid
and
they don't censor people who are
actually crazy and don't give and don't
have anything to say i remember when
they started censoring it was just going
to be alex jones and everybody was four
on the left and i'm like you [ __ ]
morons
uh you're an independent news space on
youtube don't you think this is gonna
you don't see how this works you have no
a sense of history and i said this on
the young turks
to the to one of the ceos of the young
turks on air i said you're an idiot
because uh as soon as you say something
that goes against the establishment
they're gonna come for you and now look
who's gonna getting uh censored
everybody's getting censored it went
from alex jones now it goes to the guy
who invented the mrna vaccine technology
now he's not allowed to talk on social
media anymore so it started with alex
jones it went to rfk jr they banned a
kennedy then they banned donald trump a
president of the united states and now
they're banning the guy who invented the
mrna vaccine technology and the
democrats are cheering it on the people
who consider themselves left but if
you're voting for joe biden you're
voting for an extreme right winger and
that's what people in america don't
understand in any other country joe
biden would be considered an extreme
right winger why would you say that
jimmy because he's against universal
health care if anybody in any other
country is against universal health care
i'm pretty sure they're considered an
extreme right winger so this is the
world we're living in now where
everything is politicized in the united
states and then the people who voted for
joe biden repeat the establishment
narrative that fuels this culture war
kyle rittenhouse is a perfect example
kyle rittenhouse they uh
shot three people in kenosha wisconsin
during a
riot where they were setting buildings
on fire and people were attacking him he
shot three of them it was uh they called
him a racist and a white supremacist for
a year straight and then the trial
happened and nobody realized he had only
shot white people
he only got white people who were
attacking him and i said boy he must be
a real remedial white supremacist
because he only shoots white people he
doesn't maybe he's colorblind and he
doesn't know how to be a good white
supremacist so uh and just saying that
just me saying that kyle rittenhouse
shot three white people people call me a
right winger for saying that i'm not
kidding
so the biggest uh
the most attention i got and that's why
i go by jimmy dirkback left
was when i had on what they call a
boogaloo boy no boogaloo boys are
different from proud boys and proud boys
are known to be a very like extreme
white nationalist group uh uh
far-right uh political types right
uh hang on a second jimmy look i don't
know a lot about the proud boys but
isn't there isn't that leader latino
isn't he like a puerto rican i don't
know anything i really don't know about
the proud boys
i had a boogaloo boy on so i saw i
brought on a boogaloo boy now the blue
glue boys were invented
as a reaction to the proud boys right
there are people who are gun nuts and
they're called they call themselves
libertarians but they're
they're anti-racist they're pro-black
lives matter they provided um uh
security for black lives matter protests
uh they're they're pro lgbtq in fact the
guy i interviewed was gay
uh
and they were reaching out to people
across every political spectrum in peace
and they said we need to come together
so i brought that guy on my show i
interviewed him that's when i got all
these hit pieces written on me in new
york magazine newsweek they all came out
and wrote these these hit pieces and
then they i trended on twitter for three
days because they had all their trolls
on twitter come after me and uh that it
made me trend for three days i loved it
um
and attention is great uh so
jimmy jimmy can i can i ask you a
question because i feel you and i are
quite similar where we are politically
so a little bit of background about me i
was a stand-up comedian for 11 years
before that i was a teacher for many
years i worked in some of the poorest
boroughs
in london with kids you know real real
desperate situations real poverty
i have never been described by anybody
particularly my friends on the right as
being on the right but immediately you
start questioning
the left narrative you question like i
had a friend jump down my throat because
i took the piss out of kamala harris
right he said you can't tell
why is that why is it that they have a
narrative
it's a cult go for it explain it because
it's a goddamn call well it happened to
me when i wouldn't vote for hillary
clinton the democratic party and the dnc
the democratic national committee and
hillary clinton were revealed through
wikileaks to be completely corrupt and
they rigged the 2016 primary which is
why three people had to step down from
the dnc including the chair when it was
revealed
uh
and i was like i'm not voting for this
uh i'm not voting for
hillary clinton she's the worst
and
you know eight years of barack obama uh
so that there's barack obama
governed exactly like ronald reagan
would have or or john mccain or mitt
romney there was no difference between
barack obama and a republican he ramped
up the wars he took us from two wars to
seven he put he uh deported more
hispanics and put those kids and he
deported more hispanics than donald
trump did by double
uh and so it's just he puts a pretty
face on the horrible stuff our
government was doing and so i'm i'm not
gonna vote for hillary clinton uh to put
a nice face on the horrible stuff we're
doing i'm not doing that anymore i'm not
gonna vote for joe biden and joe biden
is just donald trump uh but demented
[Laughter]
i think we will lead with that quote for
this interview jimmy uh listen you're
making some very interesting points and
i almost regret having asked you about
covert because i'm
tired of talking about it and the points
you're making are far more interesting
to me so let's delve more into that
because you talked about how america is
not a democracy you talked about a
princeton study to the people that
already are aware of you and your
positions that that will make sense but
to a lot of our audience i don't think
they've ever heard that so what the hell
are you talking about when america is
the beacon of democracy and everyone in
the world looks up to america like
what's wrong with american democracy
jimmy well american democracy runs on
cash and the cash comes from
corporations and billionaires and that's
who they serve so if you remember uh
noam chomsky wrote a book called
manufacturing consent taught you how the
establishment news actually just
manufactures consent for the people who
own them
and that's the same thing for the
politicians they're owned
uh so they can't run without cash and
they we have
forever political campaigns so cop so
politicians are forever fundraising uh
joe biden's first uh
a campaign stop was with a bunch of
executives from comcast right which is
always voted the worst company to work
for in the world comcast a huge media
company in the united states and he
promised them that nothing will
fundamentally change
and it's not uh we don't have a living
wage we don't have student debt relief
we don't have health care we don't even
have a public option and joe biden has
more debts with the vaccine than donald
trump had without
so
uh
their politicians are beholden to their
donor class we call it the donor class
and those are the oligarchs and they'll
even say it uh i i did a segment one
time where a billionaire was on msnbc
complaining and warning nancy pelosi
that if she doesn't stop demonizing
billionaires he's gonna take their money
away from the democratic party and so he
they give orders to politicians who does
the billionaire class wall street those
are the people who run our country which
is why 80 percent of workers live
paycheck to paycheck in the united
states
30 uh uh 50 of all wage earners earn
less than 30 000 a year
and uh
50 of americans can't afford a 400
emergency so that's what happens so i
always try to tell people what what do
you call a system that takes the richest
country the face of the earth has ever
seen and
deems half of it people
poor or low income you call that a
failed system
and so we're living in a failed system
it's an oligarchy they did a study in
princeton and it revealed that the if
you are in the uh bottom 90 of wage
earners
uh
if your desires is never reflected
in legislation but let's say if you're
in the upper 10 of the wealthy in the
united states and let's say
so there's a direct correlation if they
want something it becomes legislation
the bottom 90
it doesn't become legislation they have
no re no representation basically and so
that's why i say we live in an oligarchy
it was proven we all know it but it had
to be proven through a study they proved
it and so our democracy has been taken
we
should have health care
republicans and democrats both favor a
single-payer health care system in the
united states they won't even not only
will they not vote on it or give it to
us they won't even talk about it they're
not even talking about it so
that's work that's what i mean when i
say we live in an oligarchy uh and i i
see and what's interesting to me is
obviously uh the reason people accuse
you of being right wing is you're happy
to go on a show like tucker carlson or
talk to people who are who who you agree
with on certain issues right do you not
worry uh and i'm curious i'm not making
this accusation but i'm curious whether
you don't worry about
working with people on whom with whom
you might disagree on some other very
profound issues
uh no
uh i don't worry about that if anybody's
against war i'll work with them to end
war if anybody is for julian assange and
press freedom i'll work with them and if
half the country needs to hear that
message i'll go on a show that speaks to
half the country to give my message to
them tucker carlson said when i the uh
one of the last times i was on his show
he said that uh i changed his mind on
julian assange through the power of my
arguments
and that's exactly what used to be the
gold standard as a lefty is that you're
supposed to have a message for people
you're supposed to have a message for
people who are disaffected and being uh
oppressed by the establishment you're
supposed to have a message for him but
in the united states now like when i
brought on that guy who was a boogaloo
boy that was the end because that was
the left populous left and the populist
right coming together and that's the
thing that scares them the most so they
had to stop that and when i go on tucker
carlson that's me the populist left
speaking to the populist right and they
can't have that so they got to stop that
you know democrats have been going on
fox news forever i mean bill o'reilly
had on barack obama uh dianne feinstein
uh he's it was to be a regular on fox
news sunday they they go on everybody
goes on fox news because they speak to
half the country but as soon as you go
on fox news to actually bring an
anti-establishment message to half the
country that's when it's right-wing and
you're a bad person and you're
supporting all the bad things in the
world
uh and people like to make tucker
carlson out to be worse
than nancy
than rachel maddow
no i don't rachel maddow pushed an
evidence-free conspiracy theory that red
baited the president of the united
states she's for censorship she's for
our foreign entanglements uh
she's pro-war which makes her pro she's
got blood on her hands and she props up
the system that gives us these these
wars and she lies to the american people
on the regular she's lying about coven
at nuclear speed at the top of her lungs
all the time and of course it'll never
get censored because she's lying in uh
to prop up the corporate narrative so if
you lie at the behest of the
establishment there's never a price to
pay but if you tell the truth that blows
up the narrative of the establishment
that's when you'll be taken down and
you'll be smeared look what they do to
glenn greenwald now look what they do to
uh matt taibi look what they do to
anybody who challenges the establishment
status quo you're immediately deemed a
white nationalist a racist a right
winger a grifter they only do that
that's amazing uh through all through
coven i ended every one of my shows by
saying keep your money nobody has a job
right now because we're in a lockdown so
keep your money at the same time every
other youtuber was begging for donations
and doing fundraising campaigns but then
they call me the grifter i take i don't
take any corporate money i take my money
from my donors and they can't stand so
that's how so because i have brought
appeal and people on the populist right
share the ideas that i'm actually
pushing for and i'll work with them uh
that's a that's a threat and they have
to stop that and that's the more we're
in now
hey francis would you like to learn
another language no mike already know
foreign language is perfectly boy gary
ooh a little biblioteca
you can't go on holiday mate without
knowing where the swimming pool is le
bible tech is the library you idiot
exactly you can never be too far away
from knowledge and sexually frustrated
librarians
for those of you who do want to learn a
language and connect with another
culture or maybe just brush up in your
spanish for the next holiday babble is
the app for you babble's 15 minute
lessons make it the perfect way to learn
a new language on the go babble designs
their courses with practical real world
conversations in mind things you're
going to use in everyday life like
finding out where the bibliotheque is
babel lessons were created by over 100
language experts meaning real people so
you learn useful vocabulary and not
meaningless phrases like the ones
francis keeps uttering babel's teaching
method has been scientifically proven to
be effective across multiple studies
with babel you can choose from 14
different languages including spanish
french italians and the other ones babel
is available as an app or online and
your progress will be synced across all
devices babel is offering our listeners
six months free with the purchase of a
six month subscription with our promo
code which is trigger go to babble.com
forward slash play and use promo code
trigger for an extra six months for free
we're even gonna get francis on it you
might learn english
that's b a b b e l dot com forward slash
play promo code trigger i use babble and
look at me now your boy
absolutely perfecto know what i mean
gary
jimmy why is it right that
i look as
as somebody who still considers myself
to be on the left
what you're saying practically
everything i agree with and i support
except they're not taking money
i'm half latin american it's what we do
it's our culture stop judging right okay
but here's the thing jimmy
why is it that i look at people on the
left they don't talk about this they
talk about identity politics ad nauseum
and to the point where
what they talk about has got no
relevance to the vast majority of people
either who live in america or in the uk
the people outside the big cities the
average person struggling month on month
just to make it to the end of the month
why is it they don't talk on that and
why is it they focus on these ridiculous
subjects that nobody cares about or only
a tiny percentage of people care about
oh because they've so the establishment
again in lieu of actually doing
something to improve your life
what they do is they uh distract you by
putting someone in power who looks like
you to also suppress you and oppress you
right uh so for
my the joke i do if it was 1860
the democrats would be bragging about
their first transgendered slave owner
[Laughter]
and so that's what they do they i it's
obvious that's what then so the
establishment has co-opted identity
politics and they use it against people
they use it to keep people from doing
anything for them that would help their
economics or their financial anything
that would help so we're not going to
give you health care but we'll have uh
we'll have uh a gay black person keep it
from you right just that's what barack
obama was barack obama was the black guy
to come do the bidding of wall street
and so everybody got fooled
because it's a black guy you wouldn't
think that he would be a tool of wall
street the military-industrial complex
big pharma and by the way barack obama
said he wouldn't sign a health care bill
that didn't have a public option he
signed a health care bill that didn't
have a public option and he never gave
us but he gave us a right wing health
care plan that has for profit and minute
that barack obama passed that health
care plan the stock prices of health
insurance companies a big pharma went
through the roof because they knew that
was a giveaway to them not to people
people still go bankrupt i went bankrupt
i got sick and i in in the united states
i had a bone problem i went i had as
health insurance i went back and
bankrupt everybody goes bankrupt and
everybody knows it and that's why
everybody wants to have uh universal
health care medicare for all the united
states
uh now and i just cut i i want to make
this point before
i i go any further until
uh lawrence o'donnell hosts a show here
on msnbc and he used to work uh for a
guy who ran the senate uh for a while
right so he knows politics and he knows
democratic politics and lawrence
o'donnell said one time before he had a
show
uh he said that you'll never get the
democratic party
to come to your point of view you can't
pull them left until you're willing to
show you're not going to vote for them
and so that's the thing that they're not
willing to do so people who voted for
bernie sanders voted for hillary clinton
people who voted for bernie sanders
voted for joe biden and i tried to tell
them until you're willing to not vote
for democrats and stop donating to them
you'll never have a change in government
you're going to keep getting this and so
that's what i've been trying to start a
another major party well i've been help
i'm not trying other people are doing it
i'm just trying to help them and uh
that's insane ralph nader made the same
point in 2000 so 21 years ago ralph
vader said what we need to get is 10 to
15 million people not that we can win a
national election but we can we are the
king makers because nobody can get
elected without us
and that's what we should have did we
didn't bernie sanders is a
charlatan because he preached revolution
but what he did was he took all that
revolutionary energy from the
progressives and he followed it right
back into the pro-wall street pro-war
anti-worker party where it dies
and that's exactly so that's what shama
sawan who's an elected socialist in
seattle
on my show she said that wrote the the
the
the road inside the democratic party for
progressives leads to a graveyard so
there's no there's no future in the so
if i want 15 minimum wage i'm gonna have
to fight the democrats if i want health
care i'm gonna have to fight the
democrats if i want to end the wars i'm
gonna have to fight the democrats if i
want immigration reform i'm gonna have
to fight the democrats if i want prison
reform gonna have to fight the democrat
no matter what you want to get done
there's a democrat standing in your way
and that's the problem and one more
thing i'd like to say about
mandates
is they don't make sense from a worker
perspective i had on a marxist economist
richard wolff on my show that said it's
ridiculous that the left is pushing for
mandates and ostracizing anybody who's
any workers who are against them you're
just pushing them into the hands of the
right wing we should be using those
people who are against who are
anti-authority as in our political
process and our political goal but
they're they're letting them go that's
one the
the second reason why i'm against
mandates is because they've been lying
to us about the effects of vaccines
since they started first they said that
vaccines stop the virus and they stop
you from transmitting it or getting it
well they don't do that and they always
knew that but they lied to us
and
i just saw a headline today uh the fact
that it from australia the fact that
half the patients in the icu are
vaccinated proves that the vaccine is
working that's a real headline i just
tweeted out that's a real headline so um
if you can transmit the virus and you
can contract the virus if you're
vaccinated
and every by the way here's another
thing people don't know everyone's going
to get coronavirus there's no getting
out of this the virus is never going
away
and it's always going to be here they
never tell you that on the news and they
never tell you no matter how many
[ __ ] masks you wear or how many
vaccines you take you are still going to
get that [ __ ] virus
and no matter how many quarantines or
how many vaccine passports
you are still getting [ __ ]
coronavirus that is a [ __ ] tactic
and uh so if you're going to get the
coronavirus who the [ __ ]
and you can still spread it if if you're
vaccinated and you can still contract it
if you're vaccinated who the [ __ ] do you
care if you get it from someone who's
vaccinated or unvaccinated that doesn't
make logical sense and when people when
i ask people that question they start to
do circular logic they talk in circles
and there's it doesn't make so you're
going to get coronavirus who do you care
if you get it from what you should be
doing is being prepared to get it and
they never tell you that how do you
prepare to get it jimmy well you get
your vitamin d3 way up you get your
vitamin k2 way up you get your zinc up
you get uh you can find out where you
can get monoclonal antibodies when you
get sick they don't talk about or
fluvoxamine which has been proven to fit
and then they also suppress the early
treatments
they also i urge everyone to go to the
nih's own website and look up uh
ivermectin and this the studies they did
with covin
the best you can get is the cdc will say
there's not enough evidence to recommend
for ivorectin or against it but they did
tell everybody it was a horse medicine
they did lie to everybody and tell
everybody that a medicine that was on
the who's list of essential medicines is
somehow poison and you're a crazy person
if you take it even though it's one of
the safest drugs in history and it's
been prescribed over three billion times
that's the power of big pharma
springhold on the media in the united
states and those are the same people who
control our politicians
so that's where we're at and that's why
vaccine mandates are [ __ ] [ __ ]
uh well good yeah well said and i'm glad
to see you sitting on the fence jimmy
well nobody can answer that question if
there's a vaccinated person who has
coronavirus yeah unvaccinated person who
has coronavirus
why do you care who
right yeah i think
we've get it
yeah absolutely look we've made these
very points even in our episode where we
talked about our experience of getting
covered we had it quite badly but one of
the points that i think everyone agrees
with now especially with omicron which
is so contagious it has an r of of 10
right
everyone's gonna get it and so in
addition to all the things you listed uh
you can lose weight by the way you can
get in shape all of these things that i
haven't been talking during covent i
lost five months during coven just by
because i had to cook at home
yeah and yeah and they don't tell people
that the that most of the people who end
up in the hospital are obese elderly
with comorbidities it's not healthy
people most of the people are ob they
don't tell you that they don't tell you
by the way uh vitamin d3 all those but
those make a huge difference not a
little a huge difference go ahead yeah
well jimmy i was going to ask you one of
the things that
look i i am not perfect and i'm biased
in my own ways and i make mistakes but
one of the things that i always do try
to be and pride myself on being as much
as i can and i fail but i do is to be
intellectually consistent right so for
example if i were on the left i don't
know two minutes ago and i believe the
big pharma the root of all evil
and the the evilest corporations in the
world and they're all about money and
they don't give a [ __ ] about actually
treating people and helping them
and then the pandemic comes along and
big pharma comes out with the product
i wouldn't necessarily immediately go oh
big farm is the best thing ever i think
they're really looking after people but
there seems to be a thing and that's
just one example out of hundreds right
because when donald trump closed the
border that was racist and now we have
the guardian the most left-wing
newspaper in the country going we need
to shut the border and and that
people can seem to not be able to
understand that there's a connection
between that same act
irrespective of who's doing it so what
is it about the sort of that way of
thinking that allows people to
completely bypass any previous things
they've thought any previous things
they've said and just go this is now the
message i'm going to believe this now
and it's counter to everything i've said
for my entire life but i'm okay
so fear i mean that's how
if they can make you afraid enough if
they fight they can find your fear
button they can control you and that's
what's happening
look at noam chomsky lost his mind
nom chomsky lost his [ __ ] mind he's
so afraid you see he's afraid to go get
his hair cut
and if you believe in the vaccines
that's what it's another thing if you
believe in the vaccines why are you
afraid why are you [ __ ] your pants
about catching the virus if you believe
in the vaccine why won't you go get your
[ __ ] haircut if the vaccines work and
you're going to mandate that other
people take them which is what chomsky
wants to do he must have forced a
medical procedure against people's will
and if they don't go along with it he
said we should isolate them from society
and when asked how do we what about them
getting food he said that's their
problem
that's how [ __ ] crazy chomsky is now
and i'm one of the only guys who'll call
him out and hit his his and he won't
come on my show he'll go on anybody's
show to answer questions he won't come
on my show because he knows he's [ __ ]
wrong about this he's wrong on the side
he was wrong on force to vote for [ __ ]
sake anyway he's he's turned he chomsky
has uh really let a lot of people down
uh he's every four year he tells you to
vote for democrats no matter what as if
it makes a difference he said he had to
vote for joe biden because of climate
change joe biden just gave more fracking
permits than [ __ ] and more drilling
permits on national land than trump ever
did it's all [ __ ] it's all we it's a
one-party rule and when guys like
chomsky pretend it's not they're doing a
disservice to everybody when he pretends
the democratic party is somehow better
the democratic party is the enabler
they're the pretty face of horrible
corporate destruction that's what barack
obama was barack obama was the black
santa claus for wall street
so um i forget your question though
don't worry about the question jimmy
you're doing fine without me um jimmy
here's a question for you
i've always seen authoritarianism
as being the problem the rights problem
by and large you know when i grew up now
obviously you know the communism blah
blah blah but i've seen authoritarianism
and the love for authoritarianism and
the desire for vaccine mandates spring
up for people on the left people who i
would never have believed in my wildest
dreams people like chomsky
they that they would believe in this and
that they would support these policies
what the [ __ ] has happened
um
i it's fear is all i can say uh they've
turned they're pro-censorship they did a
poll people who consider themselves
lefty again you're not lefty if you
voted for joe biden joe biden is an
extreme right winger but the people who
traditionally were considered left
are uh now for censorship well
when hillary clinton ran for president
uh chuck schumer who is the democratic
party leader in the senate
he he said on a
uh talk show
that they didn't care if they lost
blue-collar workers as voters as their
voting base the democrats said this
they go for every blue-collar voter we
lose we're going to gain two and three
white-collar
republicans in the suburbs
that so they're literally saying we're
trying to get
republicans to vote for us
and that's kind of what has happened
the democratic party became the party of
big business wall street the
military-industrial complex and now we
have two parties representing them
nobody represents the workers nobody
and so that's the that's and so that's
where we're left with in america again i
forgot the question well jimmy it's not
just america i mean we have the same
problem here in the uk where the labour
party it's literally called the labour
party uh it went from being
you know people who went through the
trade unions and minors and and train
off you know whatever now they're all
you know highly educated they went to
oxford uh they studied politics and
economics or whatever it was or
diversity or whatever is the you know
whatever it is that they study um and
that party i think is less
representative of working people than
even the conservative party which it got
elected on the backs of working people
in northern areas uh and elected an
older tony and like the very embodiment
of privilege and a complete clown as it
turns out as well in boris johnson uh
but on that so it seems to be not just
in the us this is happening in other
countries as well where
that portion of the left just really
doesn't give a [ __ ] about the people
that actually used to form the base of
their party
yeah and that's why guys like donald
trump got elected
and that's why i think that's why i
think things like brexit happen they
realize they don't have any political
representation i know they don't i'm not
i mean i don't know that much about the
uk
i know jeremy corbyn uh
uh as soon as he advocates for the
workers that he gets called an
anti-semite uh you know any way to smear
him as you can just like they do me i
mean that what if if if you're actually
going to advocate for workers you're a
threat
and they're going to try to smear you
it's
there's there is no represent i mean
neoliberalism
people don't know what that is but
uh it's both we don't know what that is
what is neoliberalism explain it to us
jimmy yeah so to me it's the it's the
it's the it's
it's you you're it's identity politics
right it's your liberal on all on the
surface you know the words of democracy
but you serve the corporations and you
don't serve the people and and and it's
a it's about imperialism the united
states
uh about invading poor brown countries
uh stealing their natural resources
funneling them to huge corporations to
me that's that's when i think of
neoliberalism that's what i think a
liberal is supposed to be somebody who's
anti-authoritarian
a liberal is supposed to be somebody
who's for the people is for freedom for
freedom of speech uh neoliberals are the
exact opposite they're for censorship
they're against workers they're against
unions they're uh for the corporations i
mean to me that that's what i think of
maybe i'm wrong i'm not the smartest guy
in the world i'm not an academic that's
for sure i'm also a comedian a nightclub
comedian entertaining drunks my whole
career and then uh turns out the news is
so shitty it's so corrupted in the
united states that i can do a way better
job than people who get millions and
millions of dollars to do the news the
news is just propaganda in the united
states 100
and that terror and at the moment joe
rogan seems to be fighting his own
personal battle against them by
platforming all the people you know who
have their accounts taken down etc etc
how long can this go on for jimmy
because a populist and its citizens that
no longer have faith in the media shows
that society is broken as far as i'm
concerned right and that's why joe rogan
gets 11 million downloads per podcast
and cnn gets less than a million people
watching theirs so i mean he's just
destroying them and why
because he's not propaganda joe rogan is
an honest
uh actor and people sense it and uh he
reaches across the aisle he you know he
endorsed uh bernie sanders but they want
to make him seem like he's a crazy
right-winger because that's what a cult
does and the democratic party is a cult
and look what happened to sarah
silverman look what happened to pat and
oswald sarah silverman criticized an
msnbc news reader for lying
and she did lie
and she was meeting and the news reader
was african-american she was immediately
pilloried as a racist as a person you
would never say that to a white woman
and she had to apologize
she had to apologize for criticizing a
news person for lying
[Music]
she goes i'm sorry
she goes boy i didn't i don't want any
trouble
and they did the same thing for me and i
said guess what i'm gonna take some
[ __ ] trouble i'm not gonna knuckle
under to the establishment i'll take the
trouble i'm gonna tell the truth and
when a news person's lying i'm not gonna
go along with the [ __ ] lie and i'm
not gonna go along with the smear
after i call out their lie and that's
what they did look what pat and oswalt
did pat also took a picture with dave
chappelle he had he had to [ __ ] have
him do a maya culpa because he took a
picture with somebody
or he's out of the cult
that's it sarah silverman you're out of
the cult pat nozzle you're out of the
cult and they will do anything to stay
in the cult
isn't that the problem jimmy they do
anything to stay in the cult yeah when
actually people like us people like you
people like joe rogan will say no
[ __ ] you and that means that we stand up
and they become less powerful but the
people who capitulate just make them
more powerful
yes and that's sad and i you know i
sympathize with them what are they good
what are they supposed to do not work in
show business anymore they're in a tough
spot i under i you know i blame the
culture i don't blame them but joe rogan
is kicking everyone's ass and he's not
gonna stop
and people aren't gonna you know i just
saw so they had these fake doctors 250
doctors signed a letter to spotify
saying you should have someone on to
counter joe rogan's misinformation
meanwhile mainstream news has been lying
about covet at the top of their lungs
for [ __ ] two straight years and they
lie about everything but they want to
but on joe rogan it's it's dangerous
because he has a counter narrative to
their [ __ ] they want him to bring
out hey why don't you make msnbc and cnn
bring on dr robert malone why don't you
ever [ __ ] make that why don't you
ever make that demand that nbc and cbs
they they have to have balance no one
ever they never brought on anybody to
debunk russiagate they never brought on
anybody that had a counter narrative to
coven mandates vaccines none of it they
have to go on joe rogan's show and by
the way joe rogan i've i heard i don't
know how accurate this is but i heard
that his uh interview with dr robert
malone got 40 million downloads
so by trying to censor him they again it
had what they call the streisand effect
which is when you try to when you try to
hide something and censor it and silence
it you just get more attention to it and
uh people more people see it and that's
exactly what happened with dr robert
malone on joe rogan's show and now they
want joe rogan and spotify to have
balance nobody else has [ __ ] balance
in the news media and the biggest
purveyor of misinformation is the estab
versus the government and then the
second one is the establishment news
media joe rogan's not the problem joe
rogan is the antidote to the problem
well this is why i said recently even
though i do think both peter mccullough
and malone probably are wrong on a lot
of things in my opinion now i'm not a
medic but i do think that
i still respect joe for having them on
and the reason i say that is to me
the effects of this sort of censorship
where essentially uh the big tech
companies now decide what the truth is
is far worse than someone going on a
podcast and saying some things that may
later turn out to be medical
misinformation i just that's how i feel
and the reason i say this is i remember
the day i woke up and i saw the the new
york post had posted an article about
hunter biden
and then i saw
that every single big tech company this
is on the eve of a pivotal election in
your country jimmy
and every big tech company just went no
you're not sharing this story it's
russian disinformation and let's be
let's call it what it is you know people
can talk about election interference and
i'm sure it happens both ways but that
was blatant election interference and
these people are now claiming that they
know what the truth is [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you
and that's why i love what joe is doing
even though i think some of the things
that these guests are saying are wrong
because someone needs to push back
against this [ __ ] the government is
always lying the cdc and the fda are the
fda gets 70 of its budget from big
pharma when they have to approve a drug
or a vaccine it's they're they're not an
independent organization and when donald
trump was president
uh guess what every democrat was saying
the same thing that i don't trust
governor cuomo in new york said i don't
trust the process and i don't trust the
fda
i do want to ask you about that
especially as pertains to the vaccine we
saw dr fauci last night say that he
trusts the experts at the fbi at the fda
how confident are you in the approval
process of the fda right now
well first
how confident am i
i'm not that confident but my opinion
doesn't matter i don't believe the
american people are that confident
you're going to say to the american
people now here's a vaccine it was new
it was done quickly but trust this
federal administration and their health
administration that it's safe
and
we're not 100 sure of the consequences i
think it's going to be a very skeptical
american public about taking the vaccine
and they should be
he was then they wanted him to be the
next democratic president before he got
uh kicked out of office for killing all
those old people and sexually harassing
everyone and
joe biden said he was vaccine hesitant
kamala harris said she wouldn't take the
bat they all sent a version of this
and then all of a sudden joe biden
becomes president now they completely
flip their tune and i'm supposed to
believe them joe biden's a [ __ ]
pathological liar he's a bigger lie he's
just as big a liar as trump and uh i've
got the receipts to prove it the guy's
uh and he's demented and they're lying
to us that this guy isn't demented and
i'm supposed to believe them [ __ ] you
fauci is a criminal he should be in jail
there's a movie called the dallas buyers
club which stars matthew mcconaughey and
it's just how uh how the uh the
government fauci [ __ ] over aids
patients by keeping drugs that could
help them away just like they did with
covent they've suppressed early
treatments with coven just so you know
this
and uh and they're still doing it
and they still won't tell you about
vitamin d vitamin c vitamin k2
zinc monoclonals they'll never mention
that [ __ ] but what do they say ad
hominem masks vaccines that's it masks
and vaccines massive vaccines that's all
they say so i have a problem with
youtube i go so what am i supposed
because i'm not supposed to go against
the fda or cdc guidelines and anything i
say i go well what happens when they're
lying don't i get to call them out
because they're lying all the time and
they go no you don't get to call them up
[Laughter]
and look his that's the problem because
before you could go on youtube and give
an alternative a counter narrative but
now that's not even an option eight
months ago or a year ago if you had said
hey listen kobe probably came from a lab
and here are the reasons why and here
are these very learned intellectual
scientists who are going to explain that
to you that would be gone overnight yeah
and now we think that's definitely what
happened yeah right and you're allowed
to talk about now it's the truth again
jimmy it wasn't the truth now it is the
truth well fauci first said mask didn't
work and don't bother
and then two months later he said yeah
everybody's got to wear a mask and they
said well you said nobody should wear he
said yeah i was lying
then he literally said that he goes yeah
i was lying then
uh because i was afraid people would go
out and buy masks and we needed mass for
our hospital workers so i lied to
everybody and that guy still has his job
i'm supposed to [ __ ] believe anything
that guy says and i'm the conspiracy nut
because i questioned a guy who admitted
he lied
and that guy should be in jail how many
people died because they didn't wear a
mask and they got coronavirus and
[ __ ] died because of it
you tell me so uh he lied about hurt
immunity and he lied about funding gain
of function he lied to congress which he
should be in jail of course he's lying
at the behest of the oligarchs so
they'll never they'll never even have a
hearing you know they never even had a
hearing about the torture program george
bush ordered there was never even a
hearing about they're literally ordering
there's what's still going on they're
still there's they still have a torture
facility in guantanamo and uh you know
that no so that's it
we're done uh
uh
and and and the people who vote democrat
pretend that they're
they're fighting fascism and
authoritarianism that trump is some kind
of crazy fascist no you guys are
actually uh voting for it and you're for
it they're for censorship they're four
authoritarian lockdowns and they've been
lying to you since day one we're never
getting rid of the virus there's no way
to ever get rid of the virus omicron
presents as a cold
and so dr robert malone when he came on
my show said this he said what you want
to have the virus do
is you want to vaccinate the people who
are at risk you want to vaccinate the
elderly and people with co-morbidities
and the obese you want to make sure you
vaccinate them but you let the virus
circulate in healthy people then it will
mutate to become more infectious and
less deadly if you over vaccinate
everybody this is what robert malone
said if you over vaccinate healthy
people it creates just like when you use
too many antibiotics on farm animals and
then it becomes resistant to the
antibiotics and that's what will happen
to a virus that's what he said and then
it will mutate to become more deadly
or more resistant to the vaccines and
you don't want that and that's exactly
the process that they're they're under
right now vaccinate everyone boost
everyone the who is strongly against
first world countries do using boosters
it's on their website because they
haven't gotten the vaccines to poor
countries yeah right and why haven't
they gotten the vaccines to poor
countries if they think vaccines will
end the pandemic is because there's no
money to be made in giving the vaccine
to poor countries your [ __ ] chumps
that's why that you know that bill gates
by the way he was a college dropout why
are people interviewing him about a
[ __ ] pandemic or a virus or a vaccine
why because he's really rich and he
controls the news media by giving them
money that's why people are
why the [ __ ] would we listen to bill
gates this guy who's got a he's the one
who wouldn't let oxford oxford was going
to give away their vaccine for free he
said don't do it
and not and they didn't and so now
everyone's making millions of dollars or
billions of dollars off the vaccine so
that's who bill gates is
and bill gates also uh a good friend of
jeffrey epstein so looks like he's a
pedophile and a criminal and he's bought
the news media and why are we turning to
him for it he he's not a virologist he's
not even a college graduate
jimmy before we go on i should explain
that here in the united kingdom we have
very different libel laws to the ones
you have over there in america so i am
going to add the word allegedly
[Music]
[Laughter]
i can't say for certain that he is but
it certainly looks like he's a
pedophile to be fair we also can't say
that he's not a pedophile we just don't
know yeah we don't know and it certainly
looks like he's a corrupt criminal for
sure 100
but what we do know is that windows is
not a good operating system that we do
know jimmy but listen monopolist he's a
greedy capitalist monopolist
and of course he's doing the same thing
with his vaccines
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website well if you do then easy
dns are the company for you easy dns is
the perfect domain name registrar
provider and web host for you they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be council culture d
platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies he knows a bit about
that so will you in a second easy dns
have rock-solid network infrastructure
and incredible customer support they're
in your corner no matter what the world
throws at you unless it's your
ex-girlfriend in which case you're on
your own you'd know about that
move your domains and websites over to
easy dns right now all you've got to do
is head over to easydns.com
forward slash triggered and use our
promo code which is of course triggered
as well and you will get 50 off with the
initial purchase sign up for their
newsletter access of easy that tells you
everything you need to know about
technology privacy and censorship let me
ask you that
i want to ask you this question and look
nobody knows the answer to this
but i'm going to ask you anyway but i'm
going to ask you anyway because
you've been operating this space a long
time
do you think the spotify eventually are
going to kick rogan out the door no
there's going to be
interesting why
so i don't think people don't realize
this that
joe rogan had his show on youtube
youtube is owned by google
guess who owns spotify
google
so they wanted to take him off of
youtube because he's getting too much
heat but they didn't want to lose his
revenue so they put him over on spotify
so now because everybody they're writing
articles about youtube and getting them
uh the advertisers nervous about
advertising on youtube so they're like
let's take care of this let's make sure
we can get all the money and that's put
him on spotify get all the money from
joe rogan without having to worry about
advertisers and [ __ ] like that
uh that's what that was uh
it's isn't that interesting to know that
spotify is owned by google google i
didn't know that i didn't know that i
know that now that makes a lot of sense
so so you think the numbers talk joe
does huge numbers and they're just gonna
let him do what he does on spotify
yeah joe rogan i i don't he didn't even
need spotify like you know i mean i know
he he could have just wanted to do
joergan.com and just i mean he's that
big
that he's bigger i think he's bigger
than the platforms that you know i mean
he's not bigger than youtube obviously
but
he's big enough that he doesn't need
them
and
i think i think i mean again i'm not i'm
not a i'm no business genius believe me
i don't know but i would
so i could be wrong about this but uh i
don't think joe rogan needs a uh a a
corporation to give him a platform
but
he's that i think that's why he said he
took the spotify deal was because they
kept demonetizing his videos on youtube
and so he goes i do a show and i don't
get to make any money off it and they
[ __ ] about it and i gotta you know i'm
paying to make the show
and and so he decided well i'm gonna i
don't want to be censored anymore i'm
gonna go to spotify and so i i wish i
wish spotify would make me an offer i
would go in a second because i'm tired
uh it's really um
it it's really grating and it's
exhausting uh to worry about being it's
not only censored but worry about having
your channel taken down because they
already censored me uh already and but
they won't tell me what i did
yeah we have the same thing we have
people can give you a time stamp in the
video
and they go no we can't can you give me
the words i said that you didn't like no
those are internal documents i go you
know this doesn't pass the smell test
right that this sounds corrupt that you
guys are just targeting me
if you won't give me the [ __ ]
receipts on what you said i said and
they're like well that's just the way it
works for everybody and i go no that's
why you guys are corrupt
that's what i think jimmy i think it's
actually worse than they are targeting
you or us because we have exact same
problems what's happened is they're a
massive multinational
global corporation that outsources this
[ __ ] to a call center somewhere in india
where you've got a guy who doesn't
understand the american culture or the
american system or the british system or
freedom of speech or any of that just
making decisions you've got
it's a 20 year old in silicon valley or
whatever it is it's like one person has
this tremendous amount of power and they
don't give a [ __ ]
they're not trying to work these things
out on the basis of principles it's just
the thing to them and i don't think it's
even it goes into some kind of massive
uh
conspiracy against voices like ours i
just think we're not very important and
they don't spend much time or energy on
it and they don't really give a [ __ ]
because they're a monopoly they don't
have to explain anything to you or us
because where else are we going to go no
one is ever going to compete with
youtube if if they get
you know just like like rumble right so
rumble's big thing is they won't censor
you and so i'm on rumble uh but i told
the guy
when i was signing up that
when he was he was making the pitch to
me please jimmy come
you know use our use our uh
our platform we'd like to have you on
our platform
and i said sure i i'm glad that you guys
won't censor and he said oh we'll never
sense her i go well eventually you're
going to censor
and they said no we're not going to i go
well yes i mean if this works and it
becomes really popular youtube's going
to buy you and then it's over they go no
we won't ever sell i go everybody has a
price
and youtube has the money you know
they're gonna give they [ __ ] [ __ ]
facebook bought what did they buy
instagram for no they did they bought
instagram for like 20 billion dollars
right and what's that they bought
whatsapp
i mean who can resist 20 billion dollars
you can't resist [ __ ] 20 billion
nobody can do that and so
uh
there will never be a platform to rival
youtube and so in the united states what
we need to do is nationalize youtube
just
uh and make it a public utility
right so then all the same
laws that apply
uh like free speech we have free speech
laws in the united states and that would
apply to youtube and then yeah so that's
what we need to do and we need to break
it up i don't know how they do that they
but they but people who are smarter than
me say you can break up break it up like
places like facebook
and places like uh youtube now google
and face so here's the thing that people
don't realize in the united states
70 or 80 percent of the people get their
news from google and facebook right so
what does that tell you well it tells
you that
two companies control
most of the flow of information in the
united states that's not good for a
healthy democracy
and that's actually bad and both of
those places are censoring at the behest
of the establishment so that's why we
gotta
however you can break them up break them
up but i say nationalize them and
because right now they can take away
someone's youtube channel or someone's
twitter account or someone's facebook
account and what i try to explain to
people that you know 20 years ago
everybody knew if you were going to open
a business or be a public person you
have to have a phone right you have to
have a phone to be able to do business
in the united states and that's why it's
considered a public utility and it's
regulated right so att can't take away
your phone if they listen in on your
conversations and they don't like the
[ __ ] you're saying oh you're saying
auntie you're saying misinformation over
the phone so we're going to take your
phone away nobody nobody thinks that
that should happen but they'll let them
take away your facebook or your twitter
or your youtube because they don't like
what you're saying well that's you can't
run a business today without having a
facebook or a twitter account and in my
case youtube uh all those things should
be public utilities because you can't
function in today's society without them
and so you shouldn't let a corporation
dictate who gets to be in society and
who doesn't if it's really a public
square which it is
social media is the new town square you
should be able to say whatever you want
under the first amendment protections in
the united states but turns out
you know there's a quote that the price
of liberty is eternal vigilance
and
uh we are not vigilant in the united
states because i had no idea half the
country or even more of it would be
yearning for censorship they cheer it on
people with youtube channels
who are in the lefty news space cheer
they say i have no problem with youtube
uh kicking someone off if they violate
their terms of service
that's just shocking to me
that's what youtubers say who are in the
space
so uh
yeah we're living in a we're living in
george orwell's 1984 we're living in
brave new world by aldous huxley it's
here
and
uh like the frog in the pot people
didn't notice that they're it's now
boiling
and they're they're they're kicking
people uh i've said they fired 72 000
health care workers in the middle of a
deadly pandemic in new york because they
wouldn't get vaccinated
does that sound like they care about
people's health care when they're firing
72 000 health care workers people who
just work through a covent pandemic when
there was no vaccine and they were
heroes and now you're firing those same
people 72 000 of them in the middle of a
deadly pandemic i don't think this is
about people's health because they don't
give us health care in the united states
they give us a vaccine if it was about
our health they give us [ __ ] health
care and they're never going to do that
a good positive note to end the show on
jimmy we're running out of time man
thank you so much for coming on the show
we as always we're going to ask you a
couple of questions for our locals in a
second but before we do that we have our
usual final question for you which is
always what's the one thing we're not
talking about but we really should be
boy i i wish i knew i uh
i i the thing i find that people aren't
talking about is
you're going to get covid so get ready
for it and here's how you get ready for
it get your vitamin d3 up get your zinc
up get your k2 up find out where you can
get monoclonal antibodies fluvoxamine
get a doctor who's willing to prescribe
you things and not be intimidated by the
cdc and the thing that no one's talking
about is that everyone is going to get
coveted no matter how many vaccines you
get no matter how many masks you wear
you are going to get it so you should
prepare to get it and who do you care if
you get it from a vaccinated person or
an unvaccinated person and these
mandates are not about health these
mandates are to mandate that a
corporation gets profits
there we go jimmy dore it's been an
absolute pleasure jimmy if people want
to find you online where's the best
place to do that jimmydorecomedy.com
jimmy thanks so much for coming on we'll
do our questions for locals but in the
meantime it's been a real pleasure
chatting with you thank you so much and
thank you all for watching and listening
we back very soon with another brilliant
episode like this one or raw show all of
them go out at 7 7pm uk time and for
those of you who like your trigonometry
on the go it's also available as a
podcast take care and see you soon guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the bell button so that you never miss
another fantastic episode and if you
believe that the work we do here at
trigonometry is important support us by
joining our locals community using the
link below